have you seen this TV show on Amazon
called the man in the high castle no
what is it it's a future it's basically
America if the Nazis won the war whoa
and they partnered with the Japanese Wow
and the Japanese owned California
Northern California and the Nazis on the
rest of the country
and the Midwest is sort of a no-man's
land so New York is not seen New York
they split it at the Rockies but but
Japanese whoa third season I'm obsessed
with it Philip dick is the oh no he's
the mayor he's great this guy that guy's
been a lot of stuff what is his name I
forgot it the actor's name Rudy see well
Rufus see well that yeah that I say it
yeah New York what's the Reuben foofer
the ABBA groovin proofer is the
governing Fuhrer is it governor in New
York yeah but it's a very interesting
show basically New York cops wearing
Nazi armband so there's still New York
cops like hey the Fuhrer says I gotta
give you a ticket you know it's like
that and it's fascinating how they do
the show but what's interesting about
Japanese culture in the show is you see
the the fancy class the the aristocratic
class of Japan runs essentially San
Francisco and you see how they're very
snobby and very particular and and mmm
they don't really like to mix with the
Americans Wow with the Anglos that guy
philip k dick you know yeah he really is
he's really uh he's really super cool
like in terms of the sci-fi stuff and
I'm yeah you know what else is he
written I've seen there was another
movie that I saw of his like within the
last two years right could you could you
bring up his uh it looks because I would
know what other movies that he do or did
they do they adapt of his movies
what do we got here so this guy Joe
Scanner Darkly
Wow that's right damn he wrote a lot of
[ __ ] the adjustment team isn't at a
movie - hmm bureau okay interesting
yeah the art direction is really cool
the idea of not so fine America you know
what's interesting too is you can still
do that in a movie where you can still
play Nazis as long as they're you know
the bad people and some historical thing
or some something that's going on now
that's really the only way you could
portray Nazis like you're not allowed to
be a Nazi for Halloween sorry Yeah right
you can't
people have said like TV people have
tried it and you call out for it like
there's rules now
you can't be it you can be a knight on
that show what are you what did your
kids go for Halloween did they do they
do that or maids
it was very adorable there were mermaids
but when you're if you're going dressing
up for Halloween you could be so many
terrible things right you could be
vampires and werewolves and demons and
everybody's are very cool cool taters I
went as a plastic straw Genghis Khan
Genghis Khan can't be Hitler you could
be Saddam Hussein and people will laugh
yes Saddam Hussein we got them we got
that guy but if he dresses Mengele
you've ruined the party if you dress as
Osama bin Laden that might get your ass
kicked you might get your ass kicked
right for that one or though it's too
soon
but if you dress like you could probably
dress like the President of Iran
what's that dude's name that dude that
came over here and said a bunch of crazy
people
Abu Shah Baba I'm talking about what why
it's just talk about it for a second I
remember when people were offended that
there was a Anne Frank Halloween costume
mm-hmm now if the point of talking about
the Holocaust or something like that is
never forget and a fourteen-year-old in
a non mocking way wants to embody Anne
Frank why is that offensive I don't
understand that but they're never gonna
do it non mocking every time you're
making hallway and cause
you're almost always trying to be silly
right Halloween accost but I don't know
it all depends on to me your intentions
a hundred percent you should be able to
wear whatever the [ __ ] you want
notoya Brenda stood when that Prince
Harry got all this [ __ ] for dressing
like a Nazi it's like I don't know maybe
we did you dress like a Nazi he just for
it was a costume party yeah and all the
World War two veterans like what you
know what would you do why would you do
that you know cuz it doesn't mean he's
horrifying it does it i guess if he's
the prince right but you could be a
mongol you could be one of the Mongol
horde tour through Europe but he's also
a symbol unto itself he's too symbol of
the English royalty and all because it's
hundreds of thousands of years later but
he grew up alright he got out of it that
motherfucker's living under a microscope
though I mean but when he can get away
with but pretty much no one can get away
with being a Nazi anymore there was a
guy from like North Carolina or
something like that
recently him and his son were Nazis for
one person that can get away with it and
I can't say too much cuz we haven't
released it yet but okay Gilbert
Godfried you know I know if you're a Jew
you can get away with it yeah you can
yeah everybody zips you know well then -
yes alright go ahead
yeah you're right I mean remember when
she did that she dressed as a Nazi yeah
I always think that stuff's funny when I
was a 13 year old kid in Hebrew school
or grade school learning about the First
Amendment this is one of the reasons I
became a comedian was because I used to
just draw swastika on my notebooks just
because just because I knew they would
teach us about dictatorships that I
would go wow so in any other country
they can't do this and I would just do
it make myself smile and then cross it
out and I go in any other country I'd
get my tongue cut out I know that's the
beautiful thing is that you can say
[ __ ] up terrible you can dress like an
[ __ ] like bad taste is not a crime